Okay, so here's my solution to that.
I started by adding a constant in; K equals 16, like we talked about.
So now if you think about this, we're going to have thread blocks,
each of which is responsible for a tile in the matrix.
Let's draw that.
We'll be processing this matrix in blocks called tiles,
each tile corresponding to a single in the thread block.
Here's the new kernel I wrote.
Very similar to the previous one.
The difference is that now I need to compute the INJ values,
not just the I values,
and that computation involves using the block index as well as the thread index,
so the block index times K plus the thread index plus x.x
gives me my I value.
Similarly, I get my J value from the Y,
and so now the threads in my grid have an overall index, X and Y,
as well as an index within their block, which is the thread index.
So I am going to compute that X and Y,
and that's going to correspond to the INJ of the output matrix,
and that's the calculation that's going on here.
And finally I do the same final calculation that I've done all along.
I go and grab an element from the input matrix, equal to the coordinates IJ,
and I write that into the output matrix,
the location of the output matrix corresponding to element JI,
and here's how I'm going to call it.
Now I need to define the number of blocks and the number of threads,
which is simply N over K, N over K.
I'm being a little lazy here; you can tell.
I'm assuming that N is a multiple of K.
There's K by K threads in a block,
and now when I launch, instead of launching a single thread, I launch blocks threads.
N over K by N over K,
and instead of launching 1,024 elements or N elements,
I'm going to launch K by K elements per block.
Let's go and compile and run this.
Okay, now we're talking.
So now we're down to about 0.67 milliseconds.
Let's make a note.
And thinking about what we've done here is
we've now extracted the maximum amount of parallelism from the application, right?
We started with a single serial code, 1 thread doing all the work.
We switched to a code that used 1 thread per row of the input matrix,
and now we're down to something that uses 1 thread per element.
There's really no more parallelism that we can extract here,
And you can see that increasing the parallelism has really helped us.